we just put something underneath it okay
a lot of people think China's taking
over the world they think that because
China has a big economy and they're said
to be growing still pretty fast much
faster than the US two or three times
faster
what's missed there is what's growing
even faster than China's economy is
China's debt since 2008 the US has
borrowed a lot of money but China has
borrowed about three times as much we're
talking about 20 trillion dollars or so
the worst performance in world history
on debt you go one step down to the
industry part China does have a very big
industrial sector probably biggest in
the world bigger than the United States
and they're saying it's growing at 6%
which is a pretty fast clip but what
they don't say is that rail freight
which is how you carry a lot of the
industrial production is actually
shrinking they don't say that poor
Freight which is another way to carry
industrial production is growing only
about half the speed of industrial
production so one possibility is China
is building a lot of stuff there's not
going anywhere it's just sitting it's
not being sold which means the companies
that build it aren't making money and
guess what companies that don't make
money have to do they have to borrow
gets us back to the dead so is the bald
guy right let me know in the comments
section and let us know what other
topics you want a AEI scholars to cover
in 60 seconds
you